[Music]
hey hey Laker fans get excited LeBron
James is officially taking his talents
to LA we're excited to be here I'm
excited to be here the big news was
announced via LeBrons agency on Twitter
a four year contract worth a hundred and
fifty four million dollars LeBron James
brand has been putting it in a direction
that's really good right now
celebrities immediately took to social
media to share their excitement Chrissy
Teigen Snoop Dogg and Ryan Seacrest all
welcomed King James to Hollywood
retired Lakers icons Kareem abdul-jabbar
and Kobe Bryant tweeted their support
and Arnold Schwarzenegger was so pumped
he even made a video this is so exciting
that you coming to the city of stars and
you without any doubt going to be the
biggest star ball on the court and off
the court
love it hopefully with LeBron spending
more time in LA we'll see more of him on
the big screen like he was in trainwreck
why do I have to pick up the chin LeBron
James and of course his hilarious cameo
on Entourage what did you give LeBron
I'll match it gave a million Vince yeah
for the kids
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]